[Music]
we're going back to fluids
my favorite we're going to talk about
the drag equation
this tells us the friction or the air
resistance
i.e the drag acting on an object
which is moving through a fluid let's
say our sphere is moving that way then
as it does as it moves through the air
the air pushes back
and it's going to create this frictional
air resistance drag
force and we actually have an equation
for what that is
the air being fluid by the way you keep
saying fluid but air is a fluid right
fluids are things that change
shape to fit the container that they are
inside
so all gases or liquids even some things
that you might think of solids
blend over into fluid so yes here we're
thinking air is definitely a fluid
for the purposes of fluid dynamics in
this particular equation
so the equation says that the drag force
is equal
to one half times rho where this
is the fluid density multiplied by my
velocity
squared multiplied by the drag
coefficient
cd so this will depend on your object
the shape of your object what it's made
from lots of things are going to affect
this
finally a which we call the
2d projected area so you can think of
this
as the bit of your object that's kind of
like hitting
that wall there the leading face the
leading face yes
so if you were to test my artistic
talents so if you're like a car
you really got like the bonnet and then
kind of it kind of angles up and this
would be like your windscreen and then
like the roof
so for and then you'd have your tyres
sticking out so this is a car coming
towards you
this area here is the frontal area
because this is what the air hits
as the car is coming towards you so
imagine like in all of these situations
the frontal area is as the object is
moving towards you what do you see
and this is it we just need to know
these values and this will give us
the drag force for a particular object
also it is important to say that
this will vary depending on the reynolds
number
which is something i've talked about
before and what we tend to assume here
is that the flow is turbulent so that
means you're working here with a
reynolds number of about
10 to the fourth that is true for
dropping a ball off a building that is
true for a car driving
it's turbulent flow that's when this
equation is true if you have
laminar flow which is a bit more relaxed
chill you're going much more slowly
then it's a different equation you get
what's called a linear drag equation but
we're talking about
turbulent flow quadratic drag this form
so if i have my
sphere and i've got the air coming at it
like this then this has a cd value of
0.47
if we then compare that to say a cube
this has a drag coefficient
of 1.05 and then something else that
perhaps some of you picked up on is the
orientation here is going to be
important
so if we change the cube and had it same
size
put it on its side like this and then
you have the air coming in
it makes it more aerodynamic the air is
going to hit and kind of pass around
that shape so here the drag coefficient
goes down
there's less drag because it's a more
streamlined shape tom does the
material the object is made of make a
difference towards drag coefficient
yes it will in some context i think
if you've got a sphere that's let's say
made from metal versus made from
um lead it's not really gonna have a big
effect oh because it's still there
it is a metal it's definitely having no
having no idea okay
if you've got like a steel sphere versus
let's say a concrete sphere it's still
smooth enough
that the change would hardly have an
effect but if you had a
steel sphere versus i don't know a
sphere made of like candy floss
that's going to have an effect because
they're actually there are like holes in
the candy floss so if it's like made of
like a mesh
there are holes and that's what's going
to have an effect or even it's more the
the
smoothness of the surface so like a golf
ball
is a sphere but has a lower drag
coefficient because it has the dimples
to make it more aerodynamic so with the
angled cube
just to sort of complete this it
actually drops from 1.05 to 0.8
and then the most streamlined thing it's
literally called a streamlined body
or an aerofoil this has a drag
coefficient of 0.04
these things this shape kind of comes
out of the the actual
computation and calculation of how do we
make this as small as possible
so the air kind of comes in it sort of
separates here and goes around
like so and then this tail kind of
causes it to come back together at the
end
rather than it breaking off and creating
all of this turbulence behind it that
adds to the drag
so the fact that it can sort of stick
and come back together at the end
makes it really nice and streamlined so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take
some well-known objects and we're going
to pretend that we are dropping them
through the air or maybe in the ocean so
race one
uh we are doing falling objects through
the air
this is a drag race it's a drag race
okay it's a drag race yeah we're doing a
drag race
imagine taking a human being and let's
say a bowling ball
and we're going to drop both of these
out of a plane something like a normal
skydive jump let's go with that
so we're going to drop both of these
objects out of the plane and then the
drag equation
will tell you who will win the drag race
like which object will hit the ground
first between the human
and the bowling ball if got from a plane
so
we need to figure out these uh
parameters
but before we do that we also need to
think about
what other forces are actually
present in this situation so we've
talked about
drag so if this is my bowling ball which
is falling
as this is coming down the page towards
the ground the drag force
is acting in that direction it's pushing
it up
the reason it's falling in the first
place is from gravity
it's pulling it gravitational
acceleration so the force there
is mass times gravitational acceleration
so you've got a force balance and this
will be the same for the human
and so what's going to happen is when
you drop
your object you're initially at zero so
we're going to start
start from rest that is important so
we're starting from rest so we're
jumping out of a plane or dropping out
of a plane
so we're starting at zero velocity so at
the beginning
you're going to accelerate gravity is
pulling you to the earth you're going to
speed up
as you speed up velocity goes up drag
looks like velocity squared so as v goes
up drag
goes up you're going to speed up more
and more from gravity and you're going
to
have more and more drag pushing against
you and eventually
they're going to be perfectly balanced
you will not stop
you will reach a constant speed you
won't just float in the area
great so you accelerate most at the
beginning and your acceleration slows
down but your speed is continually
increasing until it reaches a flat point
and that's called your terminal velocity
whichever one has the fastest
terminal velocity will win unless you've
dropped from really really low
unless you drop from really low yeah no
you make a good point your your velocity
in general looks something like this
this is time and this is going to be
v for velocity and then you can see here
so this would be your terminal velocity
your maximum vt
so what you see is you you increase fast
faster fast and then you slow down slow
down slow down slow down slow down slow
down
and then you never get so this is the
shape that you get and you can solve the
equations and get this exact shape so we
actually know that
these the time it takes to reach your
terminal velocity on a skydive because
lots of people do it
so after three seconds you're about 50
of the way there
after eight seconds you're about 90
of the way and after 15 seconds you're
about 99
it's tending towards this as time goes
to infinity so you're probably never
going to exactly reach the total
velocity but
you're going to get so close that we can
say you are we're assuming here
we're reaching it and that's going to be
our speed and that's going to determine
who wins the race
so to actually get the equation then
we've got to solve
drag force equals gravity so we want to
know when these are equal
we know the formula for drag force so we
just say that's the half
rho v squared cd
a equals mg and this is what we're
interested in
right the velocity is what we care about
so you rearrange this
and we're going to get v equals
uh 2 mg i've got to divide by the row
the drag coefficient the area and
they've got square root
and we take the positive square root
because well we're falling down but
we have a we're taking the positive
value of velocity so this is going to be
our terminal velocity
here so in order to figure this out for
our human
and for our bowling ball we need to know
these values
and we just plug them in and whichever
one has the highest terminal velocity
is going to win our race what's your
what's your money on
human versus bowling ball i think the
bowling ball is going to hit the ground
first
okay all right yeah well we'll see we'll
see it's kind of like it's
obviously the humor is heavier but yeah
there's something else going on i think
it's more area it feels like more area
yeah and
i'm not totally confident okay all right
so so we're going for
we think it might be the bowling ball
how's the human folding yeah like star
jumping let's say kind of
sort of pancaking they're not they're
not going headphones not going head
first yeah you know
that is important so you're almost
giving your maximum amount of area you
could yes
yes yes you're not like going head first
and trying to go really fast yeah
it should be terrifying we need to just
know all of these values now two doesn't
change
gravity so i'll write that over here
because that's not going to change
that's 9.81 meters per second squared
gravitational acceleration on earth the
mass m
that matters so m a human
um 100 kg ish
that's heavy but yeah but it's around
it's a nice number yeah we like nice
numbers we're going 100 kg
a bowling ball i think around like 5 kg
they're about eight and a half pounds i
think so five kg
then we've got the air density so that
doesn't change
because we're falling through air it's a
bit of an approximation we're going to
just take it to be constant
right so one point two two five
kilograms of meter cubed is sort of
average air density i think at 15
degrees at like sea level
so obviously when you're a bit higher
off it's a bit thinner it's the same for
both of them as well so it doesn't
really matter too much does it now the
interesting ones we've got the drag
coefficient
and then we've got the area so the
bowling ball
it's a sphere we already said what the
drag coefficient of sphere was it's 0.47
so even though it has a couple of holes
for your hands they're not going to have
that big of an effect so it's about 0.47
and it is nice and smooth as well
so that's maybe maybe the super smooth
it's really well polished maybe that
overcomes the little holes for your
fingers
uh now for a human so this value this
will depend
on the human right because you can have
somebody who's really really skinny
is possibly going to be more aerodynamic
than
someone who is more round doesn't the
area take care of that there
yes but it's also going to have an
effect on the drag coefficient
as well right so the area yeah the area
is obviously gonna and you could be
hairy and not hairy exact very good yeah
hairy you're not hair
etc so so this is about between 1 and
1.3
so you can you know various experiments
have been done on humans it's somewhere
between 1 1.3
now the area so bowling ball
it's a sphere as it's coming towards you
it's 2d
projected area will be a circle you're
seeing a circle it's quite
potentially hard to visualize but it
would be a circle it's like the
projection of the sphere into 2d
it's going to be a circle so it's not
that hard to visualize you've drawn one
yeah
right so so the area there is is going
to be pi times the radius squared
i think the radius for a bowling ball is
about radius i think is 11 centimeters
for a standard
so the area is going to be naught 0.036
meters
squared it's quite a small area the area
for a human
this is going to vary quite a bit
depending on the size of your human
um i did some rough calculations
and said well using nice numbers about
two meters tall
about like half a meter wide it's kind
of like
one meter squared about ranging from
less as well that's a big human but yeah
it's a big huge so i think i think i
went for like 0.5
to 1 meter squared i think here
that was you know there's enough of a
range in there
i think i actually used one in the
calculation so it's a reasonably big
human
feel free to obviously import your own
numbers maybe measure yourself and find
out what your
frontal area is and plug it into the
void and see how fast you would be so
now we've actually got everything and we
can get
the terminal velocity so this is the big
moment whichever one of these is bigger
is going to win our race
so the human you get around 37
meters per second which is pretty fast
that is
really fast you're moving 37 meters
every second when you fall at terminal
velocity through the air now the bowling
ball say this is what your money was on
wasn't it
so the bowling ball the velocity here is
about
69 meters per second boom
boom i know all right so it's actually
wins by quite a long way
you had the right idea where you're
chatting about this right the the
bowling ball
is a lot smaller so it has a much lower
mass
so its velocity is less because m is
going down these two on the bottom
are much smaller as well the drag in the
area is so much smaller for the bowling
ball
compared to the human it really wins out
so
it would be almost twice as fast i think
if we did an average skydive somewhere
between 10 and 14 000 feet i think i did
12 000
to get a nice average number um you can
calculate this
so time to fall i think i did 4 000
meters
13 000 feet or so for the human this
would take about 108
seconds whereas the bowling ball would
take 58 seconds so just under a minute
the longboard hit the ground whereas the
human you're going like one minute 41
minute 50. so
volleyball wins quite a long way
actually have you ever been skydiving
i haven't i'd be up for it you seem like
someone who woke up
i've done a bungee jump and this kind of
put me off i always wanted to do a
bungee jump and then
the i was i got to the top and the guy
was like right you're gonna go i was
like okay fine straight away
and that that moment i don't think i
could describe
it just felt so wrong i'm facing the
ground you don't feel like you're
attached
and so it kind of scared me that if i
jumped out of a plane
i'd have the exact same like i think a
plane's
so much higher though it doesn't seem
real that's the other thing because yeah
because with the bungee you can see the
ground the plane you're just kind of
like i'm floating this is great and then
anyway i haven't done it
so now we're going to look at a second
example we're going to compare
much bigger objects and imagine dropping
them overboard from a ship
and allowing them to sink to the bottom
of the ocean because you've got the same
forces you've got gravity pulling them
down
to the depth of the ocean and you've got
the drag force pushing up
so it's in a slightly different fluid so
some of our parameters will change
but it means we can sort of pretend to
do this with larger objects
so we're going to consider the eiffel
tower versus the empire state building
versus a wrecking ball orientations and
where we're dropping them so if we have
the eiffel tower
this is where you're measuring the drag
the eiffel tower is kind of falling down
like this
turn on its side and let it drop like
that and that's because you've got all
the drag coefficients exactly that's
because
to be able to do these calculations you
need this drag coefficient and for the
eiffel tower in the empire state
building we actually have estimates of
the values
based on wind blowing into them so
that's what we need
for that particular sideways angle all
right oh so what's going to win
yeah so this time you've got like the
the very big heavy
box-like empire state like lots of
concrete and metal
you've got the eiffel tower which is a
little bit smaller
but obviously still quite tall still
quite heavy are we taking its sort of
holiness into account all the mischief
yeah yeah exactly i would say that's the
key with the eiffel tower is
the empire state is just like glass and
concrete and metal the eiffel tower's
got lots of holes
and then you've got just just to throw
it into the mix you've got just a big
like
concrete wrecking ball i reckon the
wrecking ball first
all right so is that based on the
bowling ball having one last time you
think there's something about the sphere
just the engine my intuition is it would
just plunge quickly yeah
and then i think although the one thing
you're not taking into account when
things sink
i imagine them like doing that but these
aren't going to do that are they they're
just going to push straight down yeah
yeah they're all heavy enough that
there's not yet they're going to just
drop
they are going to just drop
in that case the empire state building
all right so you think wrecking ball
first wrecking ball empire state but
the empire state pudding might beat the
wrecking ball actually
and i reckon the eiffel tower last all
right for some reason okay
so it's the same idea we need to just
know what is our terminal velocity
and whichever ones have the highest
value that is going to win
our race so now we're moving in water so
in the ocean
gravity of course doesn't change 9.81
meters per second squared
now the density does change so we're
going to do this
at the uh let's do it at the marianas
trench mariana trench
the the deepest point in the ocean at 11
000 meters so
the average density of the pacific ocean
is
1036. kilograms
per meter cubed so we've got uh gravity
doesn't change
the density is fixed for all of them
1036 kilograms so obviously
because we've changed fluid that's the
key thing that's changed here
compared to the first time the density
here is like a thousand times bigger
than what we had in air but everything
else is is still dependent on the object
so that's doing its work on the bottom
half of the equation okay
exactly so these are going to be much
slower because the number on the bottom
is now much much bigger it makes sense
you would expect to fall faster through
air than you would through water if you
jump into a pool you don't sink as fast
as if you jump out of a plane
so the objects then so we've got the
the wrecking ball just a nice big sphere
we've got the eiffel tower with lots of
holes
in it and then the empire state building
so for these three objects
we again need to know mass drag
coefficient
area so a wrecking ball average size
wrecking ball
2 250 kilograms they're heavy the
eiffel tower weighs about nine million
kilograms perhaps unsurprisingly is
pretty heavy uh the empire state though
is going to be even heavier is 365
million
kg so some very big objects these two
are much much bigger drag coefficient
we've got still a sphere the eiffel
tower so
this is estimated to be between 1.8
and 2. the holiness and the fact that it
has this steel frame
actually creates a lot of drag because
as the wind hits it
it kind of some bits go through and it
just creates lots of turbulence and
that's actually not
or as the water goes through it as the
water rather than the air like yeah so
the empire state is
a bit better so that's about 1.3 to 1.5
so definitely the most streamlined is
indeed the wrecking ball as we might
have thought but the empire state is
more streamlined than the eiffel tower
now the area
for a wrecking ball again it's a sphere
so it's going to project into a circle
so if you plug in these are about just
under half a meter
uh in radius about a meter across i've
got it as 0.67
meters squared is going to be your pi
times the radius squared the area for
the eiffel tower so you can
think of it as a triangle kind of do
half base times height but then there's
loads of holes
i've got a value here of about 750
meters squared and in the empire state
building much less holes
it's just a big old block of glass and
concrete so i've got that
estimated about 28 000 meters squared so
there's a really big difference
now plugging in the numbers this is the
this is the moment this is interesting
because
i see the mass is going to go on the top
of the equation so the mass is going to
get things moving but the mass has a
really big effect
but how big an effect but then it's also
going to be slowed down by
by this one being very big on the bottom
which one did you should we go with
which one you said
let's go let's go to the eiffel tower
the eiffel tower first all right so the
eiffel tower
plugging in all of these numbers uh this
terminal velocity
comes out about 11 meters per second
okay it doesn't mean much at this point
it's just a
it's a number what we care about is
where the other two fit so you've said
that we thought this was gonna be the
slowest yes okay so we thought i was
gonna be the slowest and the wrecking
ball was going to win
yes so let's go with that one next
because if this isn't faster then you've
just
okay so the wrecking ball then you plug
in the numbers for that
and you get 12 about 12 meters a second
wow
it's really close really really close
yeah and it's it's because
it's because of that mass because
there's such a big difference
the mass on the top there it's it's so
much times bigger it's 9 million
compared to 2 000. so you need more mass
to push through that water
yeah yeah so even though the area is
obviously so much smaller of this
the wrecking ball the eiffel tower isn't
quite big enough to really slow it down
too much
all right go on then put me out of my
misery no you do you're actually winning
so far
yeah as long as this one is somewhere
between 11 and 12. i'll see what might
happen though
so the empire state is
30 meters per second it's actually the
fastest
wow it's the biggest it's the heaviest
so yes it
makes sense it would go the fastest
but we've seen that the eiffel tower is
bigger and heavier than a wrecking ball
and goes slower
so there really is a lot it's a
it's really to do with the drag
coefficient in the area for me the
interesting thing about
drag equation and terminal velocity this
whole thing is just how important
how aerodynamic your object is and how
streamlined and that actual
frontal area that projected area making
that as small as possible
making everything nice and pointy it's
going to make you go so much faster
compared to being really heavy so when
you hear all these much
loved and hackneyed stories about
dropping ball bearings and bowling balls
off their
leaning tower of pisa and they should
hit at the same time you must be like go
away
you're not even thinking about drag well
that's the point yeah so
because the air on the earth is
sufficiently thick
it has an effect so there's a really
nice um
experiment that nasa there's actually a
nasa video of this
on the moon of one of the astronauts
dave scott
oh you've my favorite my favorite
dropping the feather in the hammer
falcon feather yeah yeah yeah yeah the
video is awesome is it
well in my left hand i have a feather
and my right hand a hammer so he drops
the hammer and the feather
and they hit the ground at the same time
and i'll drop the two of them here and
hopefully
they'll hit the ground at the same time
how about that obviously that's because
the
air is so much thinner that drag
there's nowhere well so the drag just
doesn't have that effect
whereas on earth you do have drag does
have an effect so
if you did that on earth it's not going
to happen right the ham is obviously
going to beat the feather because
there's more drag on the feather
so density because the density of the
air on the moon is zero
means you've got you've got a zero on
the bottom of your equation
does that mean it's going to ten so the
terminal velocity will just be really
big
so you'll just keep accelerating yeah if
your density is
really really small or is in fact zero
this formula says my terminal velocity
will keep
increasing regardless of mass yeah if
it's zero completely regardless of mass
yeah because because what you're going
to do instead of flattening off this
would just continue to increase
this episode has been brought to you by
brilliant in-depth interactive courses
like these ones
well that's brilliance bread and butter
but i have to admit i'm also a little
bit partial
to these daily challenges have a look at
some of these
one to five
stylish socks they are kind of stylish
and a mystery of dice
to check these out in more detail plus
everything else on the site
go to brilliant.org number five
have a look it's elegantly designed
educational and frankly
it's kind of fun too there's the address
again
brilliant.org number five by the way
there's 20
off a premium subscription unlocking
everything on the site
if you use that slash number file
this is this is the power of the
reynolds number really does the reynolds
number itself have units then
the reynolds number does not have units
the reynolds number is just a number
and we can actually see that so the
reynolds number itself
is density times length times speed
divided by viscosity